one niche youtuber i want to recommend
is uh marshall mcgee
um and he is basically a professional
sound designer who breaks down sound
designs
in like games and movies and anime oh
cool and it's like it's i feel like
because he's only like at like 50 000
subscribers okay but i feel like
it's because sound design is such a
niche topic that
nobody thinks about but he breaks it
down into like basically
he he hears like a sound from like dark
souls or something and he was like okay
here's how i would like make this sound
and he like
breaks down this entire process of like
layering really hard every sound he does
and it just
like it's i feel like sound design is
one of those topics that just doesn't
get enough appreciation oh yeah
and yeah and i feel like a channel like
marshall mcgee
like breaking down what actually goes
into this is like super interesting as
well
just like how much effort and like
knowledge it takes to be like okay
this is what i think like how do you
take a sound that doesn't exist
and like create it in your head and like
actually
make the sound that like you hear in
your head
into like into an actual into an actual
sfx yeah i mean it's like the
cartoon sounds like a boying like yeah
what makes a boying sound nothing makes
a boring sound effect yeah
i remember i remember seeing a video a
while back i don't know if it's still up
it was a really old video of
uh this guy who did who broke down one
sound
in one cartoon and it was the [ __ ]
you know in scooby-doo
you know when they go running like when
the oh they're running
yeah that sound it was just a video
breaking down how they made that sound
and why it's so iconic
yeah and just finding out what it was
and like how they made it inching like
how they came up with that i did i was
like
how do you even think of that yeah
exactly it's like it's it's just so
it's so it's something that you just
weren't expecting
it's like oh it's probably just like a
bunch of mallets it's like not
completely wrong
it's just yeah it's also strange i mean
like like think about getting punched
when you punch it doesn't make a punch
sound
you just get punched yeah yeah yeah that
was another video where i saw like a
foley artist explaining like how they
hollywood makes the punching sounds yeah
like
and they break leak to break bones yeah
it's like breaking celery
to make bones crack and [ __ ] like that's
like shit's so interesting yeah i
definitely do watch a lot of uh like
music based
uh youtubers right i think some music
ones i like uh there's a guy called joe
jeremiah he doesn't upload much but he
does like melodies of like games and
um anime shows right piano it's really
good okay it's just good
mathematicians feel like
yeah that's the one thing i [ __ ] love
about like the music youtuber community
is that so
that [ __ ] posting game is on another
phone so shitposty and yet they're all
so [ __ ] talented like davey five or
four as well yeah
504 and like seth everman's another one
and like even like
you know like uh john sudano it was
another one like
the [ __ ] like the fat dude who like
oh yeah
of all these songs but replace the
lyrics with smash mouth
shitty flute as well you look like oh
shitty flutes
i don't know like a lot of the music
content i consume is
mostly just [ __ ] posting
there's only so much you can do with it
and they've gotten really creative with
[ __ ] posting yeah yeah yeah it's called
so 10 second songs is another one that's
yeah that's really good as well it's
like super talented dude but at the end
of the day you finish the video and
you're like
i just watched the [ __ ] post that was a
[ __ ] post but it's so good